エンディング
おい、こっちピンチ頼むわ
豊臣くん、4番ピンチお願いね
はーい
今、ちょうどプラス1万点くらいだから、適当にやっといてくれよ。
はい!
いやー、トヨトミ君もここに来てまだ3日目だけど、よくやってくれてるね。
おー、いいハイパイ!
学生さ、お手柔らかに頼むよ。
おんに頼んませ。
リーチ!
え?ダブリーかよ。
え?またかよ。
勘弁してくださいよ
ピーチ!一発!ツボ!ペイ!
トヨトミ君、いったいどうしたの今日は?
見てました、マネージャー
なんかそのうち、悪いことでも起きるんじゃないの?
生んだことあるわけないっすよ。実力だもん。
アキラちゃん。
何だこいつ
クラウキンかい
だめだお前
うるさーい
何すんですか
お前はバイト先のジャンソーで俺に負けて箱かぶった通りすがりの客じゃないか
ずいぶんと説明的なセリフでな
そうや確かにワイは遊ぶ金も持たんただの通りすがりの貧乏学生や
けどそんなもんにかて
心の安らぎを求めて
ジャンソーに入ることがあったってええですよ
人んちで何言ってんだお前
ところがそのジャンソーで
アンさんはわいの心に安らぎを与えるどころか
展望をごっそりと持っていきはったんや
その上そんなわいから
寝床まで奪い取ろう
そう言いまんのんか
あのな
けど幸せは不幸の中に落ちてるもんや
わいはその手がかりを一度見つけたら、絶対に逃がさしまえへん。
それが、あんさんや、たんや、師匠。
師匠?
あったりまえでんがな。さっきのじゃんそうで直感した。
ああ、この人にはかなわん。わいは心底かんぽくしてしもうたんや。
このお方こそ、わいの師匠にふさわしいと。
ええ、そうか。
ほな、そういうことで。
ということで
だからなんなんだおめえは!
おきかいわれ!
師匠、顔色悪いですよ
当たり前だろ、俺は昨日一睡もしてない
今日、バイトは?
ない
ならメンツ集めて一仕事せなあきまへんな
いいからお前帰れよ
何言ってまんのや
アンさんはワイの師匠ですせ
あ、姉ちゃん礼行おかわり
誰なんだよお前は
ごめんなさい
トヨタミ君、待った?
なあ、いや、今来たとこ
え、いつも師匠がお世話になってます
あ、ハヤミですどうも
どなた?
アキナちゃん、そんなやつ、むしむし。
ところで、アキナさんは、麻雀はなさるんですか?
ええ、するわよ。
そりゃええわ!
キャー!
あわて、前からきれいな女の人と麻雀打つのが夢でしたよ!
いや!
あと一人誰にしまひょー?
ええ、それ俺だ、ドレス長!
アゲチ、オダ、僕があのお三人は不在で、
ママさんって人が来るそうです!
お茶、オッケー。ザボトン、オッケー。展望、オッケー。灰皿マッチ、オッケー。
まあ、まあ、師匠とアキナさんは座っといてください。
うわー、久しぶり。
遅かったじゃないですか、ババさん。
ババさん、ババさん、ちょっと聞いてくださいよ。
ところで、誰こいつ?
僕ね、大阪じゃなきのダボケンって言われてたんすよ。
へぇ、そう。
おい、ババさんは腐ってもたい。プロなんだぞ。失礼じゃないか。
僕、Cリーグのプロ。
よっしゃ!えぇ、ハイパイヤー!
おぉ、来ちゃった!
いちいちうるさいな、お前。
はっ!
ポイヤー!
チェン!
やべぇ、筋ね。
おぉ、おっとっとっとっと。
あ、当たりか?
ポージですがな、ビビらんといてくださいよ。
嫌なやつ!
シャアがドラやから、パーピンで吐くちゅんドラドラ。
マンガンやな。
じゃ、リーチ!
ありゃ!
ぽ、ぽんやぽん!ドラぽんや!
あないなリーチはドラもないてや。
安いはずやで。
これで、ドヤ!
ど、どうし?
さあ、ハネマンビシッと積もったれ!
えいっ!かんやー!
しゃー!かんやー!
ほんのおといといドラじゅう。数えやくまんや。
じーすーたろうかー!
なんどいやー!
あ、出た!
リーチ、ナミ!
えええええええええええええええ
だ、なんやこれは
あらうらどらが7つ
まんがん
ばいめんだよ
アンビリーバブル
はやみは
そんな手ドラ切ってリーチかけたらダメですや
あらどうして
きっかけよ
きっかけかてわいはでかい手やのにおりるわけないじゃろ
でもパワーきったじゃない
どういうことじゃなくて
ん?どういうこと?
そろそろプロの強さ、アキナちゃんに見せつけるとするか
理想の捨て牌
リーチ
このハンちゃん勝ちきれば
ババさん素敵!
私、強い男に抱かれたいわ
ああ、抱きやる
やるぅ!
なんでね。
ああ、かんさっぴんまるみえ。
パパさん、チャレになりまへんで。
いいちのまちがわかれば、こっちのもんやで。
ろうそ。
ぽん。
うそ。
ちんみつたんやお。
といとい。
さすがわいや。ふったあとすぐばいまんとりもどし。
うーわん。
師匠!ウーアンなんか切ったら飽きませんよ!
だってリーチの現物じゃん!
リーチの現物かて!タチャに対してもおりなあかん!
ここはワンチャン袖チーソ切りや!
うのもあるが!
いいペーコウドライチ!
あたー!チーソパーソンもちもちや!
しかもババさんの産品あんこにしとる!
つえー!
師匠!こらうかうかしてられませんよ!
ええですか。人生絶対捨てたらあかんもんがあるんですわ。
それは正義や友情なんかやおまへん。
師弟愛ですがな。師匠と弟子との深い絆。
早い話が。弟子の負けは師匠の負けなんです。
なに?
せやけど、師匠の勝ちは弟子の勝ちや。わてら一生離れられへん宿命なんやねん。
そんな勝手があっか!
へへへへへへへへね
心配することなんかなーんもなかったんや
プロもまくってワイが断トツでトップや
まだ勝負は分からんぜ
もう分かってまんがな
オーラスで2着に1万点さ
目つぶってでも勝てまんがな
言うてな
本当に目つぶって勝てよ
勝てろい
そんなもん
その代わりステイハイ言うてくださいよ
どうぞ
三品
チュン!
ドンキッデリーチ!
うううう、ようわからんな。
なんや?
あら、チートイツやな。
いいわんでもきっとこが。
キャ!でばさい!
リーチ一発、メンホン賞賛、ジャンタドラドラ!
おやで、いくらかしら?
どうしたかしら?
師匠、短い間でございましたが、 最後までお世話になりました。
ほなわてこれでー!
またかーい!
この世はゼニや!ゼニがこの世を変えるんや! それが何はの金融道!
大阪からやってきた謎の男、 自称泣きのダボケン。
はい、エドリック。また大貧民ね。
つくわー
師匠!師匠!ワイにも配ってくださいよ!
ねえ、師匠ったな!
し、コラキューロマンスカーは全席指定なんだから、5人いることがバレたらまずいだろ!
んなこと言うたかて、ワイもやりたい!
誰だ、ウメはよ
実は私も知らないの
そうだよ、お前は誰なんだ?
まったくしょうのない人たちやな!
師匠も秋名藩も馬場藩も、先日あんなに麻雀した仲やのに。
わいの名は賢人言いますのや。大阪から来ましてん。
金もなく、もう疲れ果ててしもうた。そんな時、師匠に会いましたんや。
俺は師匠じゃないっつの。
わいが師匠言うたら師匠ですがな。ええですか、わいはこれからの人材や。
わいなしでは師匠の将来も荒らしばへんのやで。
さーて、それじゃ大秘密続けよっか。
そうしよう、そうしよう。
し、師匠!
まーだよ、しゃーねーなー。
入れてやるから静かにしろってば。
ほな、わいからいきますよ。
パス
バカなやつ!最初からそんなカード出して!
やり方知らんな!
同じマークなら縦に続けてもええんでしょ?
ああ、3枚以上だったらな!
なら、これはどうやろ?
パス!
パス、パス!
ほな、ワイ、上がりや!
ズガン!
はいはい、2枚いいカードくださいよ!
やっぱりお前連れてくんじゃなかった!
分かった。
怖いわ。
大丈夫だよ。
平気だよ。
ほい、ほい、こんなに渡れないでどうしようか。
やめて。
ママさん、早く助けてください。
昨日雨だったから、水かさが増してちょうどいいわ。
行こう、行こう。
いらっしゃいませ。
お世話になります
全部で4人様ですか
そう4人だよ5人じゃねえよ
ほら嘘ついてねえぞ
ほら正直やすって呼ばれてんだぞ
それじゃごゆっくり
黙ってらっほ
師匠もう出てきてもいいです
ひどい目にあった
早速風呂でも行くか
私も入ろうっと
気持ちいい
いい湯だな
ショーショー
なんだよるな
なことよりあのドア女風呂に直通ですよ
なに
全員潜れ
ラッキー誰もいないわ
気持ちいい
おー!
もう。みんなエッチなんだから。
なんで俺だけぶたれんの?
師匠、それは愛ですよ。愛。
さあ、やるめ。やるめ。
よし。
もう俺なんかこのイソウロの分、勝たなきゃ。
師匠、頑張って下さい。
うーし。手を広げて、何斬りか?
ちゃいます、師匠。ここは安牌の何残して、数万斬りですやん。
いちいちうるさいんだよ。
この人ら手早いですやん。がめってたら切り遅れますよ。
でちぎ。
ほら言わんこっちゃない。
でへへへ。早くほら振り込むなよ。
えぇ、アンパイがない。どうしよう。
師匠、ワイに任してぇな。ここは消去法ですやん。
消去法?
ええでっか。まず4枚使いのりゃんぴんと、うぅぴんと、3枚使いのサブローソは切れへん。
裏筋のすぅわんと、うそは本命やね。
ローピン切りは、うぅろーろーか、りゃんすぅろーの方からのリーチが考えられ。
3ピン数ピンは一番臭い
すると3ワン
もちろんドラの3ワンは切れない
何も切れりゃしませんがな
わし悲しうなってきたわ
せやからなんとっときな晴れと
あれほど口を酸っぱくして言うたんです
今さらそんなこと言うたかてしゃあないわ
結局おめえ何気だよ
何にもないときはストレートにこれだ
あんた、通っちまったんだ。
よし。
どうぞ!
同じパイ金でねえよ!
よし、勝負!
数万リーチ!
あんた、しょうねえな。
こい!
ドヒコめ、リーピンズもドライチ。
なんすかそれ。
裏ドラあかんでしょうね
キョエー!
し、師匠!
麺瓶つもドラさん!
ハネマンですよー!
ここはもう、勢いに乗ってリーチですやん
ドアがどこにあるかわからない
ここは慎重にダマだ
んな、弱気ですやん
何二人でブツブツ言ってんのよ
リーチ!
あ。
来た!
9-1切ってリーチ、行きまひょうか!
行こか!
やん!
ああ!
結果論、結果論!
そら怖い!
リーチ一発ツボ!
ちーといドラドラ!
やだ!私も白マチだったのに!
ほら見ろ!ほら見ろ!ほら見ろ!ほら見ろ!
さすが淡いろう師匠やわ!
ふらとらわ!
うわー!乗らんかー!
普通乗るぞー!やってらんねーなー!
尽きませんねー!師匠!
あれ言ってるぞ!リッチー!
金持ち!
何だっけねー?
喧嘩せずです!師匠!
ロン!3900!
えぇー!?
あははは、君もなかなかやるじゃないか。
まあ、頑張りたまえよ。
ロン、2000!
黙れ、2000点。そんな手、上がってて大丈夫かい?
馬が進んだだけラッキーですやん。
ロン、1300。
だあ、細かい細かい!
ロン、1500。
ちっちゃいちっちゃい!
ロン、肉は残二。
トゥーリトル、トゥーリトル!
でんぱい。
あははははは!一人能天だよ君!
師匠、一人笑ってる場合やないで。
えっと、二万四千点。
二万四千八百点だ。
二万五千点ちょうど。
二万六千二百…
ラストの差が二千二百点のトップ?
師匠!師匠!
な、なんや?
やっと師匠に恩を返す時が来ました
実はわて大阪では逃げの剣言われてまして
今まで隠してて申し訳ありまへん
オーラスのワイの逃げ技
そこでビールでも飲みながらとくと見ててください
おうおう任せた
三式目のリャンシャン展
ドラは9アンカー
いらんわ
お前ね
トップドリは点数より動きやすさで勝負や
セオリーですや
こんなんも取ったらトップなんか取れませんよ
取れる十分取れる
三色ドラさんねばってたのに
そんなことないですよ
こっちのいいシャンテンのほうがずっとかたちいいですや!
行きまっせい!
どーん!
ピーフドライチ、2000点!
イエーイ!
あかん!
今日はついとおらんわ!
ら、らす、らす。
らすれば、らするとき。
勝負は時の運ですやん師匠
帰るわよ
長僧
全ての悲しい思い出をこの川に流そう
師匠
終わりましょうろう流しですが
去年のあなたの思い出のレコードが今でも流れています
豊臣は思うのであった
遺体の遺体の飛んで行け
というわけでケンジン君はトヨタミ君家の居候になっちゃったのでした
これからもよろしくね
よろしく頼むマッサ
次回スーパーズガン ベイビージャンシュポンタ
胃の中のジャンピューターきっと見てね
眠っちゃいや
ご視聴ありがとうございました
さあ、いかねばならぬのだ!
リッチバックビーフリーツ!
しぼちゃかんちゃばじゃん仲間
勝負かけたら、情けおれおろめないうち
君はアゲマント主席じゃないか
僕とワンガンつぼろうよ
つかんと、しあわせつかもうぞ!
スーパースタート!
やるでやるまんまくところ
飲んで 早く飲んだ
さあ 飲もう
ここは三面町どころ
行くな カンちゃん
腹心底の責任が派だ
相撲にも負けんのにやりぬいて
勝手飲み越すビールがうまい
スカッと
お酒はいどっちがけ
ご視聴ありがとうございました